[Music]
thank you good morning or I used to
probably say good afternoon everyone
welcome to the into the unknown debate
now in this debate today I'm delighted
to be joined by three fantastic speakers
so if I introduce first Elizabeth Seward
Elizabeth is senior strategist for the
Space Systems Division of Airbus the
largest builders of spacecraft and
satellites in the UK martin rees
astronomer royal and author of on the
future prospects for Humanity he is the
former president of the Royal Society
and on my right Tony Milligan
philosopher and author of nobody owns
the moon currently based at King's
College London the opening topic of
course is is it essential to reach out
into the unknown should we applaud a
return to grand adventures with the
potential to replenish the planets
depleted resources from the moon from
Mars or even from beyond or should we
give up on our space odyssey's and
recognise that the scale of space
actually leaves us trapped amid the
barren planets of our own solar system
so without further ado I'm going to kick
off with Martin Rees could you please
give us your take on this topic right
well of course we got to remember that
when men lands on the moon
that was done for political reasons and
there was no follow-up because the
Americans had spent four percent of
their federal budget on it and it wasn't
worth continuing but humans if they
explore I think we'll go as high risk
adventurers people like Sarah know fine
is prepared to take very high risks so
my scenario for manned spaceflight is
that it should not be supported by
taxpayers it should be supported by the
billionaires or in sponsorship etc and
it should be done as a adventure and
spectator sport
but I hope that some people do land on
Mars by the end of the century excepting
very high
but I think it's crazy to believe in
mass immigration to Mars too dangerous
delusion to think that we can escape
Earth's problems by going to Mars
dealing with climate change is hard but
it's a doddle compared to making Mars an
attractive place to live but if you
don't pay for
far ahead I think we can imagine that
these people are Mars are going to be an
adapted and they will use all the
technologies of bio and cyber Gangi
modification etc to adapt to that
strange environment and they will be the
precursors of our post human species and
they may become competing electronic
will become true here on earth we won't
change so fast but they will become
electronic and then if they are near
immortal then of course they would even
be able to voyage beyond our solar
system because that is certainly a post
human not human enterprise so practical
space doesn't need humans at all but I
hope there will goes on the bedroom
thank you Thank You Martin and over to
you Tony okay I think that there is
something that the machinery robots
technology can't do for us and that is
to have certain kinds of experiences no
space opens up a range of those
experiences but broadly speaking I think
I'm an agreement was with Martin about
certain aspects of this I think that the
idea of mass migration to Mars is a is a
is a crazy notion I don't think that
there is any inbuilt innate human
wanderlust that means that in some way
we would be running against our human
nature and in malcontented if we feel to
go to out into space I think in certain
respects it's a done deal
that we are going to go I don't think
the drivers for that are as we are
intrinsic to human nature
I think the drivers for that are
intrinsic to the kinds of socio-economic
political systems that we are that we
are we are generating
I would love the idea that the private
sector could carry the burden and that
it should not fall upon the a appointed
multitude I do have a reservation about
that or two reservations one is that to
some extent you have to buy your way
into influence upon programs so if
that's what we're doing in terms of
state involvement then a supposable
thing to do and and secondly I think
that if we want to go into space in a
way which abide by certain ethical
standards of justice and fairness that
it shouldn't be simply an arena for
America Russia may be and then some of
the larger players if we are to have
those other voices in space from the
smaller nations even from indigenous
people who have launch sites say it down
in the in their territory as well then
then the state has to have a rule in the
funding of space programs to try and
find pathways for those voices to be
heard
thank you and lovely over to you do you
think it's essential to human life that
we voyage into the unknown I mean I
would argue that it is and I would
challenge your for your views are on
human wanderlust and we've always
explored we've gone to the next Valley
we've crossed continents and we've
crossed oceans and we've done it to
survive we've done it to find new food
resources new land now that we're
powered by money we've do it for wealth
and for riches and rally you know sailed
the world but he did it so he could
bring back a ship full of goods for the
Queen and show his prowess with with his
new spices and things and
neurobiologists have discovered in fact
that curiosity and new discoveries are
awarded in the pleasure center of the
brain in the same way that other basic
in things like food are and if we take
this into computers and machine learning
programs that they put a reward bonus
for trying new
actually achieved better results faster
than programs without and many programs
without this extra bonus get stuck in a
loop because they can't find another way
out of a problem and so I think it is
inbuilt in us I think space has been
inspiring us for a long time I think
that the Apollo program was indeed a
political driver but that you can't
really say that we stopped when it
finished we didn't have that same
impetus as racing against the Russians
but it changed it transformed into
building the International Space Station
and collaboration with the Russians and
the collaboration that have continued
even in the face of political discord
mike.griffin is a annex administrator of
NASA and he described space exploration
as Cathedral building that in the old
days people built cathedrals for the
majesty of the building and in fact they
there were long term projects that the
the sort of instigators of sometimes
never even saw the end if you look at
the gaudi building in barcelona but
along the way they learned a lot of
other things they learned how to work
together they learnt the challenges and
the advanced civil engineering that also
benefited everybody in their normal
house buildings and so if we look at the
ground projects of space in a similar
way we are making international
partnerships and working together and
hopefully leaving something as inspiring
behind thank you so you've heard the
three pitches for the theme of this
debate now in 1969 it seemed like
exploring the solar system was sort of
the the biggest priority of our time
however now we have global warming we
have an abundant abundance of political
crises going on here on earth so the
first theme of the debate is going to be
should we go into space now is there any
point is this something we should be
exploring now and if so why so Elizabeth
if I can put that to you first of all
well I mean I've mentioned it a little
bit but the question should we be in
space almost it means mute we we did
rely on space so much in our everyday
life we build satellites for all sorts
of reasons but we use
for weather forecasting for climate
tracking for GPS so you know where you
are but also the timing the system init
is used for banking and transactions if
if we didn't do anything in space today
actually life would not be as you know
it now it would be quite different but
if we talk about people in space then
we've been in the International Space
Station since the year 2000 there have
continuously been people in orbit above
our heads
since that time so it's 19 years on now
and and there's an argument from the
scientists that the science that they do
the microgravity research isn't really
worth the cost but there are some
interesting spin-off technology so if
you look at the economics so the ISA
said that in ten years they've had a
hundred and fifty new commercial
technology so people making money of it
with 20 new companies and some of these
are things that are are essential so a
flight suit monitoring is now used for
babies and sudden infant death syndrome
or a planetary radar is being used to
detect landmines and so a lot of the
benefits from space are things that we
wouldn't even imagine when we started
but of really valuable but then should
we not then be making a distinction
between kind of closed space exploration
and like much further exploration
because obviously presumably we can't
have any advantages from far exploration
and awareness of outer space to help us
with climate change or for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute's of Arts and ideas
III TV
you